[Musik]
in der nähe von kersbach in bayern gibt
es diesen kreisverkehr auf der
verkehrsinsel steht seit kurzem ein
kunstwerk ein zitat des dichters ludwig
tieck wer den richterspruch lesen will
muss ganz langsam drum herum fahren
dabei immer nach links schauen sollte
man autofahrer am steuer wirklich zum
lesen bringen
viele halten diese kreiselkunst für eine
gefährliche schnapsidee ich habe es mal
versucht zu lesen und bin zwei mal rum
gefahren und habe es dann immer noch
nicht kapiert gehabt und dann habe ich
doch jetzt breche ich lieber aus
verkehrssicherungsgründen wenn man dann
lesen will muss man zweimal rumfahren
drei mal rum fahren und dann hat man
verkehr behindert die audio fand dann
langsam also neulich hat fast ein
auffahrunfall gegeben weil der andere
vorne stark gebremst hat der
verkehrsknoten liegt am rand eines
gewerbegebiets unweit der autobahn für
die behörden aber soll der kersbacher
kreisen zum tor zur fränkischen schweiz
werten sehnsuchtsort der deutschen
romantiker deshalb die idee mit dem
dichter spruch von ludwig tieck 49 meter
lang silbrig schimmernde metall lettern
sechs davon mit blattgold überzogen
kostenpunkt 70.000 euro autofahrerin
brigitte slepicka macht den
selbstversuch die ganze natur es den
menschen einer poetisch gestellt ist nur
ein spiegel wo er nicht langsam fahren
die polizei kontrolliert unsere test
leserin der vorwurf verkehrsbehinderung
wegen zu langsamen fahrens ohne
triftigen grund
aber die beamten sind nett verzichten
auf ein knöllchen frau slepicka hat von
der kreiselkunst nun endgültig die nase
voll
ich finde es unmöglich was hier gemacht
worden ist
die behörden haben keinerlei zweifel
dass hier alles absolut verkehrssicher
ist das schriftband und die
unterkonstruktion seien im
kollisionsgefahr muss weich ausgebildet
damit bei einem aufprall nichts passiert
und so kann man im zuständigen forscher
landratsamt die aufregung nicht
verstehen
die maßgeblichen behörden waren von
anfang an eingebunden
es wurden alle anforderungen bezüglich
der verkehrssicherheit erfüllt die
bürger sind sich da nicht so sicher
ich halte es auch für gefährlich wenn
manche leute ist wirklich leser wollen
also form einer hinsicht ist es unsicher
dieser ganze kreise
demnächst soll noch eine tafel mit einer
erläuterung der kreiselkunst hier
aufgestellt werden wo auch immer das
schild dann steht passen sie beim lesen
bitte auf sich auf